olá pessoal de quem falar que seja muito
bem vindo é na f 1 ele ou eu gostaria de
aqui um desafio aqui é um desafio que eu
gosto de fazer que tem vida com um tiro
na barriga com comida é chamado desafio
com os estragos é comer comida de bebê e
eu só não trouxe por 24 horas porque sei
que não vou conseguir aguentar mas eu
tenho muita comida de bebê embaixo vão
experimentar aqui hoje como amigos e
oakley se até lá não se pode comer
comida de bebê corre agora sim a língua
é comida de bebê que você chega lá que
essa chance sim sim e agora muito mais
eu ia tentar implementar outras coisas
que forem mais exóticos desenhar na tela
temos de batata com frango especial
inteiro e também o papa pessoal é o
vômito
ricardo e rafael e 2 - 1 fota em caraças
de energia é meu pai só uma esfera
pessoal aprovado
vejam só o aspecto destaca que no japão
ganhava mais fez instalada salvar o
ponteiro giba position a primeira coisa
pra mim tem que ter só o açúcar não tem
nem uma coisa nem chamaria com água e 50
não é 11 a primeira que vai ainda mais a
[Música]
88 em casa não é só de nós
é duro de roer patrocínio o puré de
batata e diminui o céu fica com isso
ficou apenas em quarto duplo é só
problema não é só compro nada vai me ver
assim somente terá que ser assim
isso é pra comer assim que tem que ser
assim del sol só conseguirei ii é s
[Aplausos]
[Música]
fica bem em todos então eu vou dar o
benefício da dúvida vou dar um site
nestes 50 que não né 5
está em mau momento mau uma maçã por dia
em casa com uma vez a promessa que eu
sei que vai todo num vai poder provar
isso
agora isso vai alavancar ansa
[Música]
gostava de ver o nível era bem disparou
só me live e uma coisa é bom mas é bom
na escola pública condicionada a um
milhão
[Música]
o espanhol mas vale lembrar que também
vai ser muito bom e acho que tem estado
a chuva colegas política concelhia senão
um dia eu vou deitar aquilo que é
composta também por jesus na zona é logo
ali incrível é muito bom falar de nós
[Música]
ia tirar de boiadeiro tirar eu faço a
minha opinião em uma cena da escrita
cheguei há muito se diz que uma mulher
se alguma boca assim a coisa seja isso
assim se o mogi mirim
eu nunca mais como marcenaria e fazendo
o nosso alguma coisa vamos comer e beber
eu acho que essa vai todo também fica
sempre uma guerra
isso aqui é desconhecida
não não faça
não costumo ela ainda tem que um casting
de apnéia sabe que não gosta do chefe
chega muito bem
o prejuízo mas é como eu não consigo
estado é como poderá ganhar menos salvar
o ciência hoje em dia não é o creme é o
crambe o é como eu gosto muito porque só
então começar sábado 16 17 e 51 próxima
refeição com que os peões com insetos
como juíza